[Music]
[Applause]
you look amazing boot how are you how
you oh my God you look so thank you did
you hear her oh my God I first of all I
want to say girl she's up here now and
you need to get a band you get a B get a
Bible you're good well you're back
you're in this building again you were
here for a while yeah you're used to 30
Rock I didn't even realize that the last
time I was on here we was in La yeah I
didn't even realize that I know I did
you look so that's why I'm happy here
you
good you look so good thank you um but
anyway so um do you remember like your
first audition for SNL you can't forget
stuff like that yeah I mean it was just
intense it was intense um yeah right
there on 8h do people laugh at those do
they help you know usually they don't
laugh but you're like but I'm
funny I mean I did a whole cartwheel I
did a cart a whole cartwheel I did a
cartwheel in my audition of course they
left oh my go they was like she's insane
I know but it must be what your this
just a wonderful gift you walk in a room
and you leave it better than it was
you're like you have that kind of the
nicest thing you have that that person
like that Persona that personality I
don't know everybody would say that they
you ni thing every I know you do you
asked some of my relatives he like she
leaves the room back that's because
that's because they're used to you wait
I so you're it was a big thing for you
too cuz I didn't realize that you were a
writer on SNL 2 that was actually the
first thing that's well actually I
didn't get hired as a cast member you
know they hired sasher yeah and and and
then I got hired as a writer well which
I told him I was like you know I'm not a
writer you know I was like I like to be
in front of the camera probably both but
he was like he was and he probably was
saying that too like you are a writer
you just a giving it you know love but
he was like I don't know what you are
just come he was like I didn't know I
needed you until I saw you so come oh so
I was like good don't you want someone
to say that to yeah that's nice I mean I
want a man to say that yeah me too
hey amen so
wait do you feel like there's been a
change for black female comics on SNL
yes I do I think I think that was the
main reason too I also went to audition
CU I was like you know just like Chris
said you know they don't get the
opportunity to really find a lot of
black females because we don't get to be
in the places that they go to look for
and I'm not trying to opport race or
anything I'm just telling you what it is
like yeah I ain't I don't know where the
Groundlings is I mean
I cuz that's the I don't I don't know
where you CB all I don't know where that
is I know where the comedy clubs is so
even when he when Chris told me I was
going for the audition I was like yo
dude what am I going to do I don't have
characters he was like you're the
character just do comedy and I'm like
okay whatever you know so um I feel like
my whole thing was like if y'all don't
know about black females I'm going to go
and let you know and let you see one of
the good ones so then you can go start
looking for
more no the Domino that that's
incredible you're hosting the Daily Show
again right yes yes yes do you love
doing
it I'm not going to lie to you I love it
I it's so fun I loveing love it yeah cuz
I love to talk yeah I love to fuss uh
and I love to be funny I love to bring
joy I love when people laugh it's it's
it's not just about me making you laugh
it is a function I am a doctor and I am
prescribing you medicine yeah I actually
agree with that and that's so real
whenever you can laugh like you can
laugh through something yeah no Hey
listen everybody need to cry too that's
a function also do that a lot but
laughter laughter you got to keep a
balance that's what's wrong with us
right now we don't have a balance so I
You're such such a great uh motivational
person as well did you is there a reason
why you felt like the Memoir is
important now to I don't know if I'd
ever do it okay well first first
everybody always like want me to say
something really you know Wonderful
about why I wrote this book but it was
like book agent called me and was like
you want to write a
book
yeah let's
go I I advise you to do it because you
can do it your own way that trust me
that first version thank God that one
didn't get out cuz
it has so much stuff in there because
it's it's a lot of pain it's a lot of
pain it's a lot of you remembering stuff
and and stuff in the end but then when I
read it I was like oh girl you do not
feel like that now these are things that
happen to you now explain them so people
can understand that you can still go
through stuff and end up on the good
side of it you still can go through bad
and treat people well you don't have to
be a now I now I had to go I stand on
yeah did you I I heard you you started
at was it a college comedy competition
yes yes yes that's kind of a hard like
your peers that's hard were you nervous
no I was already funny I
I and just working on that
humble that's me too look you it's not
even about being conceited it's about
being convinced no yeah you know it's
like if your doctor walked into an
office you want him to be like yeah I'm
your doctor and I know how to do this
and this is the treatment and boom boom
boom you don't want your doctor to walk
in and go I'm kind of a good doctor I
kind of I kind of feel like they said
I'm okay no you want somebody that's
confident and I'm confident I'm
confident because I've worked and I've
done the work and I'm good at what I do
so if that's what shows then take that
note because if you're good at what you
do you're good at what you do and this
is I really want to say this I am Leslie
Jones but there's going to be a billion
Leslie Jones after me and I want to make
it okay for them that's what I want now
I'm starting
look we got no we have tissue we get
tissue we have tisue CU you know when're
not preach I sweat no that's so true
like I literally thank you Brendan you
can come on this is Brendan give it
up no I I um I agree with that I I this
my therapist I had to go to therapy to
find but it was like hey why don't you
start treating yourself how you treat
others and it's like wait what that was
hard but we lie to oursel all the time
for some reason we like to have oursel
in Misery we live with it we lie and we
retell a story and it be lying you'll be
lying you be lying to hurt yourself and
that does not make sense maybe let's
just switch places here I'm going to
need like the I'm going to
[Applause]
just now here's what happened I'm just
kidding oh my God wait we found we found
an image though of um it's of the school
newspaper that interviewed you and I I
love I think a good comedian and this
what you said should be able to relate
to the audience and talk about things in
a natural way like you just did so you
still believe this you're still rolling
with you're rocking with this where did
you find
that last night I snuck into your house
I'm kidding no wait yo I don't even have
this that's crazy I said that
yeah and but you know what I think is
beautiful if somebody in this audience
including myself needed to hear exactly
what you just said but I think I think
what's incredible is you said this a
long time ago but you're still living
that same like truth you're still living
those same words which is kind of
incredible you so we going to be best
friends
that's be my best friend okay that's
that's is just a mix o um do you
remember that that moment though like
being a part it was couldn't have been
easy the whole time you had to bomb once
right you're wrong did I just over you
did I just over you I was like I didn't
even mean to like no I just think it's a
beautiful thing
how it's a beautiful thing like how how
you know you find these things from like
when you were younger and that dreamer
and then you didn't lose that that
Essence is still in you that's
awesome we're going to get you a photo
copy of this
okay I'm going to have it like
oh why are you so moved right now I need
to know exactly why cuz I didn't think I
was that
smart you are not then not then I was a
wreck I was a mess maybe you thought you
were maybe you I a 19yearold mess we all
were what 19-year-old has their together
like nobody knows 19 you can't any of
that Lord have mercy I came out here to
be beautiful
I wait we're going to get touched up in
a commercial break Leslie's book my
makeup girl Leslie
L GL mine's glow glow that's so funny
Leslie's book is called Leslie bleeping
Jon it's up now you got to go get some
change your life and everyone in our
audience is getting a
[Applause]
[Music]
copy
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home